hey what is up guys I'm cabby HD here
and I have two kind of easy finals left
which means videos this is ask mkbhd v2
on a lot of these our frequently asked
questions coming from the first ask
mkbhd v1 and a couple of other stuff
from Twitter so the first thing I got a
lot of questions asked about this week
who is Android silver which is a rumored
program to replace the Nexus program
with high-end phones that run a purified
or stock version of Android reminds me a
lot of the Google Play edition program
where I didn't think it would happen and
then it happened I didn't really see any
reason for it to but really I would say
I wouldn't hold my fingers crossed for
that I wouldn't exactly expect that to
happen because the Nexus line even
whatever you call it if it's Android
silver and Nexus or whatever it defines
the direction of Android it steers
Android if you will so when Google
decides that they want to move to
on-screen buttons and they want to get
rid of capacitive buttons that's what
they'll put in the next Nexus One they
want to decide to stop using microSD
card expansion you won't see that in the
next Nexus so if Google were to just
grab a galaxy s5 and put stock Android
on it you would still have those old
parts that they're trying to get rid of
in Android handsets so the Nexus line
whatever you call it or however it works
it still needs to be able to steer
Android the way that Google sees it so I
think we'll see a lot more about that at
Google i/o now next thing I keep getting
asked about as I've talked about it a
lot on Twitter I guess is how I've
wrecked my sleep schedule for finals
people keep asking what is your major
where you go in school for so I've
mentioned it before I'm going to school
for business and technology that's my
major and minoring in information
systems and marketing in exactly three
days I will finish my last final and be
done with my junior year so thumbs up
for that also something I mentioned in
the five facts about me video a while
back is that I was playing professional
ultimate and I still am now the team I
was playing for and no longer exists so
I am now currently playing with the New
York Rumble and our home games are like
every other week and we have away games
up and down the East Coast so I'll have
the link to the schedule of on but for
the Rumpel site below if you want to
check it out and maybe you can come to a
few games another question is who you
got in the NBA playoffs this year and
I'm going with the Clippers it's kind of
a great time for the playoffs right now
probably one of the most exciting
playoffs in NBA history
I say Clippers just because I like
watching them play and they are so much
fun to watch their games even after that
terrible game 5 loss last night but I
gotta say also fun fact my career mode
in NBA 2k14 on the ps4 my current team
is the Clippers
so naturally I'd be rooting for that
team in real life as well since they're
doing so well and that team when I'm
playing is actually having a pretty good
year so that's good and I've also gotten
a lot of individual device questions
about phones specifically so when people
ask like what's your daily driver the
typical answer to that is whatever phone
I'm using our testing right now so for
now it happens to be the one plus one
and that's probably going to be my next
phone review so that's coming soon if
you're ready for that another phone I've
gotten a lot of questions about by
popular demand is actually the Sony
Xperia z2 so I have my hands on that now
and I'll be testing that out allowed the
camera and the display the new display
are actually pretty exciting I've also
seen a lot of new rumors about this this
LG g3 that the press renders are finally
out now and it's looking like a really
hot phone so I'm pretty excited to see
that in person also um the new iPhone
has been leaked like crazy and I'm gonna
be talking a little more about that in
an upcoming video and one more thing the
Moto e that just came out which is an
even more stripped-down version of the
Moto G I reviewed it's pretty similar to
the Moto G that I've already talked
about so I won't be reviewing it but
it's only a hundred and thirty dollars
off contract which is an insane price so
I just gotta give my props to Motorola
for that they're killing it in a low-end
Android Market and well maybe they'll
talk the high-end market the same way so
here's a Twitter question has Google or
YouTube ever asked me to be in one of
those subway ads that are all over in
New York and no I haven't actually been
asked about those at all it seems for
the most part to be like makeup or
beauty gurus who like YouTube is just
full backing and trying to push those to
public with that I think it's really
cool that they're getting like these
subway ads I've actually seen them in
person taking the subway in New York so
it's neat that they're doing that kind
of stuff and hopefully tech on YouTube
will be important enough someday that
some tech youtubers will have a banner
on their face in a subway station that's
pretty cool our curved TV is only a fad
I don't know if like I saw a lot of
those curved TVs at CES this year but
didn't really get to experience them in
person but I hope to figure out
these curved panels are legit pretty
soon on video how big was the file of
the setup tour project the setup tour
project which was 2 hours and 47 minutes
long was 10 point 6 6 gigabytes and that
is quite a large 1080p file and which
MacBook would you recommend for high-end
stuff like gaming since the retina
MacBooks used so much power to push all
those pixels I would still say if you're
going to get a high-end MacBook get the
Retina Display MacBook Pro because you
can get the best specs out of a run a
display MacBook but then if you're gonna
game on it you don't have to push all
those pixels you can still run it in
1080p although if you're getting a
laptop for gaming why would you get a
MacBook I would probably not get a
MacBook if you're gonna game but yeah
either way that's it thank you for
watching this mkbhd asked video I still
think that's a weird way to title it I
don't know what else call it so but yeah
thanks for your questions again I'll get
more questions for the next episode from
the most common stuff left in the
comments section on this video or if you
hit me up on Twitter at mkbhd I'm always
there I'm talking to you guys so either
way like I said thanks again and I'll
talk to you guys in the next video peace
gonna go steady